hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John old Humphrey we are going to watch
I don't think we've ever done a reaction
of this channel and I'm surprised we
haven't because they are the king of the
reactions fine brothers entertainment
FBE now rebranded college kids react to
try not to get mad challenge Game of
Thrones little pomp I haven't seen this
video this is a topper war tier requests
at our patreon page from Eric Horseman
the man with the real rejects tattoo no
regrets am i right let's check this out
hopefully FB is cool with it try not to
get bad are you ready yeah what are we
doing we're doing one of our reactors
favorite calendars nevermind I'm not
ready
that's so bittersweet I don't think that
goes I can go either whatever hair that
sounds sarcastic so just kidding I'm mad
already mad this is happening I don't
think I get mad easily but there are
definitely certain things that push my
buttons anything that has to do with
like being cruel to another person which
I feel like it's always what I'm showing
I'm in such a good mood because I drink
coffee this morning
and now I'm gonna put me in a mood so
two burgers
[Music]
[Music]
I'm ready for it I feel like most of
these challenges start off really easier
than they get harder if you repeated it
a few more times oh it really got me but
I think that one was fun
a rare super more like try not to get it
no waiting thousands of people pass
every day to get a glimpse while taking
a picture seems innocent it could be
destroyed easily Oh majors important
park officials created the hashtag don't
do the bloom to educate influencers but
it's not stopping anyone know or
silently 150,000 posts are tagged super
blue people are so nearly 150 ever I'm
super blue so we came out here because I
wanted to get into more the alley to
slay
[Music]
disclaimer
you just have a camera maybe some good
good aesthetic so like I get it but like
dumbasses just like why when I went
there there was a whole like wire that
was basically blocking everything and
people literally ripped it and then just
ran straight into the pot Wow maybe a
hundred people that did it and the cops
are literally writing fines and stuff
because it's getting so bad there the
first time but you just keep doing it
over and over then it's like okay okay
you know you'll have to suck people just
relays and then people just listen to it
they're lazy and so to our fans at home
if you're at Game of Thrones fan skip
the next piece of the video if you don't
want spoilers but to our reactors sorry
you don't really have a choice it's not
gonna be a spoiler but I know what
you're gonna play now one week that I go
a couple days without watching it know
[Music]
[Music]
the window waiting for Suzy to die
somehow and then we get killed by Dwayne
the rock Johnson whatever are they
related I feel like everyone in the show
is just dating someone they're related
to see I didn't - I thought this bit
this being like to finish up because
Jamie throughout the entire series has
always been super flip-floppy with his
relationship with Cersei see ya Oh
sayonara
Oh watch Game of Thrones I'm sure if it
did seems a little exciting but try not
to get angry spoiling okay and you guys
[Music]
[Music]
sure it gets cold you need Starbucks you
left them Starbucks for a coffee kiosk
coffee cup a game of Thrones what's
I'll trigger just talking about it I
remember one on that set no one had
continuity or knew that there was
[Music]
because she's right but you know there
are actual humans making these shows I
need this is my forte this is what I
loved at the point yeah uploaded his
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow one Congrats to me like the actual
video no I I think they're just looping
this one part of it 10 more times if he
was gonna go one more time I was going
to take these off for our last video
we're going to show you the trailer from
a film as Twitter pretty outraged what's
this Laquisha I haven't seen this
channel welcome to the Joe show I
submitted myself to a radio station for
my own show
I don't like technically blackface but
with what if all the white people stop
this boleros see why Twitter
[Music]
I'm sorry I did not hear about that
probably smart now you should probably
should be doing that in general I'm not
going to be triggered about it but I'm
gonna be like damn that's kind of dull
he's like oh if I was the minority like
things would be so much easier for me
like okay great like you've had it much
easier your entire life because you are
a straight white man just acknowledge
your privilege and that's just there I'm
saying that's a believable concept for
something that would happen in the real
world in a bunch of um
TV shows they're animated where there's
voice actors you have voice actors that
aren't that ethnicity doing those voices
like that happens all the time so I can
understand why people are outraged but I
think you won the challenge I try to be
positive and stuff you have to always
kind of see the bright side to things
for the most part I'm a very very gentle
person but I'm definitely I definitely
got got in this everyone but when it
comes to seeing things having a feeling
about them I feel very strongly so I
guess I thought it was a sir but I'm
actually originally so I don't think it
matters that be yeah the fans and
realistic dog we release new videos all
the times to subscribe hit the bell oh
hey Ron producer here at the eat thank
you so much rocking this episode of
college kids react make sure you check
out some other episodes across all
generations so they're gonna be down the
description bye Ron that was fun
interesting compilation is it fun and
yeah that was a lot of fun it was like
more conceptual than I thought it would
be I thought it would just be like a
bunch of really micro like every night
scenes I'm mothers before I've seen the
fine brothers before by I don't know
it's been a while since I've there's
been oh we're sorry
well I haven't seen one where it's like
a medley of just random
things that are supposed to upset you
I've seen usually ones where they're
like focused on a band or on a
particular style of thing you know what
are these guys you tubers are just like
college kids who have applied to be here
because it's called college kids react
yeah I kind of imagined that they would
be college influencers they all had
handles at the top of different social
media either way then they all looked
camera-ready I feel like the one I would
always kick it with is the musician guy
Austin Austin yeah yeah he seems like he
is a chill dude he's got a hit but
strong cynicism and yeah yeah you'd be
the most fun person in Chapter he seems
like he would always have an amusing hot
take yeah the Briana girl she said
something about we're gonna go to that
Laquisha trailer that just reminded me
of something I'm encountering all the
time in LA you see you meet a lot of
actors and actresses out here a lot of
them are white all of them are
struggling actors this is what I'm
constantly hearing and man does it get
on my nerves divinity of my friends I
have a few friends who come on this
channel say this to me they will say I
wish I was a minority because I'd be
booking more if I was a minority I saw
it coming the second she said that like
it's so true I I hear all the time and
it's so frustrating like do you have any
idea how much more challenging still
yeah it is sure maybe on TV they're more
diverse in the supporting character
roles that the leads are usually white
people still and I'm not I'm not
crapping on white people at all it's not
what I'm doing I'm crapping on my people
I miss my friends and your all the time
hate my friends no matter what they're
even even like Obie's in circles at
parties and they'll be around other
Caucasian folks I don't know yeah do you
have any idea how hard it is for
minorities to book roles for years like
when I was a teenager I used to do you
know the whole child acting thing
constantly it was always why people and
then and if it was an ethnic role you
had to be like hardcore that ethnicity
how you look yeah they're too ambiguous
you have to like look full Arab you have
to look full Hispanic you know yet Billy
we need to be able to profile you at a
moment's notice yes so it's like maybe
there's more opportunities for actors
in the minority at the same time though
sprawl the ethnic actors who have made
it today their struggles are so much
more massive than what you're going
through right now seriously and what
you're experiencing is just your
majority becoming a smaller majority
yeah like there's still tons of roles
for Caucasian actors of all shapes yes
they're just maybe a couple less at the
moment because we're still figuring out
how this whole living amongst each other
thing works I haven't heard of this
Laquisha movie that does seem horribly
insensitive especially at a time like
this like someone with a guy forget
which one said it was a good point about
how in general you shouldn't be doing
this but especially now what are you
doing yeah I remember when the trailer
dropped excellent it seemed like one of
those woefully misguided things that
just falls out of the ether and I almost
expected and I think I heard one review
that sort of said like as a movie is
actually pretty low budget and knock
Lluis like it's not really that
outrageous in any direction because it's
not really that good at any particular
direction but it is kind of like
carelessly offensive because it's just
coming from a place that is so out of
touch but what that Austin I said was so
funny you know at first I was like oh
you want me to be mad because this is
just badly produced I thought it was
supposed to be MacOS is poorly produced
just like watching the the the moral
implication wind him over to the anger
the whole thing that we're going over
with the poppy fields I mean most of
these to be annoyed I'd be annoyed by
majority of these what they discern the
difference on fine brothers would they
be like well technically if all through
the mass spectrum it seems they X you
out as soon as you raise some sort of
active negative wings yeah what's your
like I don't like this they're gonna
ding you but I like the poppies alone
made me realize like if I just saw like
a couple people taking the pictures I
probably wouldn't mind but like you see
this footage of like just hoards of
people all just they're on phones like I
had to kind of be happy when I at least
saw one group with like a bounce board
and you know like a professional camera
and I was like at least you bothered but
in general I get very annoyed
is when I see people just taking photos
at places when it's clearly Instagram
modeling when I went to the Getty and
there's a statue and you're you're
literally doing a modeling poses there
on a Sunday afternoon I get you have
your professions I do same time I'm
gonna be annoyed when you have like a
horde of people disrupting the
environment that that is you know yeah
and it becomes yeah an objectionable
thing or like I don't know who these
people were went to a wedding recently
there were these it was like fields and
cabins and then off to the side during
the reception I don't know who these two
were they were provided to the wedding
so whoever literally her and this guy
they brought a professional camera and
they were taking all these modeling
photos I'm like we're at a wedding right
now you can't help but get annoyed by
[ __ ] like that but then when you're
harming the environment and sitting on
these flight literally you sit on them
you're destroying the flowers yeah the
thing and it's like no man again it's
like if it's plumber to my people I
understand but when you see ya just like
30 40 50 people out there all doing it
you're like yeah flowers are gonna get
trampled yeah you know Game of Thrones
we've we've said a lot it's funny we're
it's still in the like I don't know how
it is in other parts of the United
States but definitely in LA it's still
in the zeitgeist look it's brought up
constantly
yes something we all lived through and
can commiserate about you should what's
funny is I'm not finding anyone who's
like you know the more I've thought
about it the more effective it seems to
be the exact opposite even for myself or
like yeah I just something else I just
thought about this just cut me a little
bit more before I think about it I'm
less mad I'm just more sad and it's
funny too because they picked one of the
most maddening scenes to show here with
Jamie and Cersei yeah that was
interesting and this Gucci gang song oh
yeah little pub Gucci gang you all right
so we just cut it to actually listen to
the Gucci gang song cuz I've never heard
it before
Oh
what do you think I mean it's not as
annoying is just looping that one part
yeah a little pump it hasn't lost the
billion views oh my god oh when this
song landed it just everyone was too no
matter if you thought it was terrible or
quite a vibe everyone was talking about
this long I can't listen to this song
without watching them video yes video
has so much more going on that the
actual song sounds like he got high
heard a beat and just said [ __ ] over it
yeah expression throughout this video
has the same kind of blank expression
like space down saying thank you stare
and then the two minutes of rambling
they turned into a music video that is
more impressive okay and then Thai girl
do a lot for your production value
alright guys what you can subscribe to
the fine brothers subscribe to the real
rejects click notification bells thanks
Eric for requesting this video eric is a
guy who owns an obnoxious amount of
animals I think the last I'm going to
talk to him I don't remember off the top
my head wouldn't be surprised if I was
completely on point with this I think he
owns like six cats right now wow that's
a lot of cat is that legal and he has a
raccoon and opossum that visits him Oh
at his home too it's like they're
animals that live around the
neighborhood and then he feeds them to
under separate note I can see why Eric
would love this video because he's
constantly getting mad about stuff oh
yeah we message back and forth and he'll
get enraged about things I just hope
that would that co-worker you were
having issues with you don't harm that
human being and if you need tips on how
to properly dispose of the body I'm your
guy I have helped get rid of so many
bodies it's to the point where I should
get paid to do it I wish there was some
type of app I could create
where if you need to get rid of a dead
body
you could call upon me dude just
download the new corpsey app we should
probably change the subject
Erik's also gay ooh and happy Pride
Month on that we're celebrating we
should celebrate straight Pride Month oh
definitely let's get that that wonderful
straight flag that we created and then
why privilege month oh yeah definitely
that let's all address in our white
robes so that we're because then that's
how we're Pierre Lee white you know this
isn't wide enough could always give way
honestly Eric there's so much stuff you
say to me in the messages that I could
co-op I'm gonna keep this light yes and
this is the version of light I can go up
an exquisite course
stream-of-consciousness see you guys